okay selena i love what i'm doing right
now it's enjoying my life and i'm
getting to do things that i'm passionate
about with the people that i love check
out selena gomez getting cozy with film
producer andrea irvelino during her
italian getaway the actress who recently
celebrated her 30th birthday was
captured out on the amalfi coast with
the suave producer as they enjoyed an
intimate dinner for selena who by the
way looks glamorous as she dons a one
shoulder dress while cutting her cake
andrea stands by her side as he rocks
off white pants a white button down and
a navy blue blazer with both looking
very italian chic thank you i appreciate
i tried the two were also caught during
a boat day outing selena is in a lime
green short set and andrea wears a denim
shirt and white pants he also helps her
onto the boat what a gentleman now it's
not clear if these two are actually an
item or dating but they seem to be
pretty comfortable with subtle pda i'm
now a little bit picky
and if they are indeed a couple he must
be the creme de la creme because as
selena told et last month the bar for
men in her life has been set pretty high
thanks in part to her only murders in
the building co-stars steve martin and
martin short well i think in general
i've said this before but i think in
general my standards for humor and
gentlemen and just uh professionals um
have been you know the bar's been lifted
pretty high working with these two given
what you just said i mean oliver and
charles meddle in mabel's relationship a
little bit this season are these guys
meddling in your real-life romantic
relationships are they trying to set you
up with anybody no
no
just just me you guys don't have a
rolodex of they're protective they're
we're very protective over but but you
know most of them also you know are dead
we don't know anyone under 50. so it's
not like uh say i want you to meet
selena if you get out of that walker
maybe you can meet selena only time will
tell if selena is indeed off the market
but one thing we do know is that 30
looks good on her she celebrated with a
lavish bash in los angeles with all her
closest loved ones and as we've seen on
her tic toc she's prioritizing some self
love and humor as she lives it up in
italy suck it in
i'm not sucking [ __ ]
why real stomachs is coming
okay i know that's right sal keep living
it up
[Music]
you